Donald Trump joined an emergency prayer
call after his Mar-A-Lago speech which
came after his arrest he was joined by
Michelle Bachmann and referred to our
beautiful Christianity which he says I
guess is under attack folks if Trump is
turning to prayer and to God you know
that he's scared and that is indeed the
vibe I get here the audio quality is of
course terrible Trump says we are losing
our religion he says that's me in the
corner no okay we're losing our religion
and he's desperate I guess for donations
money and prayer take a listen we're
being discriminated against as a
religion we're being discriminated by
the way I have not doctored the audio to
make it worse it's genuinely this bad
very hard for uh for the people of our
country but I'm very exciting very hard
for people of religious people that
believe in God people that believe in
faith and it's an honor to have so many
and that was a cough coughing is really
common on these prayer calls my friend
John McCall uh as you know we're going
through a fake uh investigation That's
What It Is by radical left
I believe actually have to hate our
country but we're winning we had a great
day today actually because it turned out
to be the Sham and it's turning out to
be that and we have others down the line
but we're we've been winning them for
eight years now ever since we came down
the golden escalators they call it a
Trump Tower
things that have always remained solid
on that is our faith our religion our
Christianity our beautiful Christianity
and all two or maybe it was three of the
Corinthians that Trump knows I think
the thing about the people I know who
can't be no greater calling than what do
you do and yeah one of the people on the
line was Paula White the woman who was
in that insane viral religious video
where she's going and strike and strike
and strike and strike and strike and
then she starts speaking in tongues she
says or something like that that's one
of the great people on the call that
Trump very much respects honestly he
sounds more desperate for donations and
money than he does for prayer and of
course maybe the country wouldn't be
less and less religious over time if it
weren't for the fact that the people
most loudly demanding the return of
public religion are absolute lunatics
wanting to completely break down any
kind of separation between church and
state this wasn't even as bad as it got
Michelle Bachmann the former Minnesota
congresswoman uh was on the emergency
prayer call and she wants uh to beseech
God or wait or to beseech I never know
who they want to be Siege but anyway
here she she weighed in as well
would you declare Donald J Trump
innocent oh father would you free Donald
Trump from his trouble yeah and our
troubles here in America oh Lord would
you have mercy on Donald J Trump and
America and would you hear this prayer
tonight from your people ruined
J Trump's reputation right
[Applause]
okay okay all right and she just went on
from there this is nuts folks this is
totally nuts and uh this I I don't know
how many donations this is going to
generate for Trump but maybe it will
generate some prayers and we'll see sort
of how effective those are